[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
happy new year's eve to all of you
really do appreciate the successful year
you guys have helped the real rejects
have it's all thanks to you guys for
watching our videos really really
appreciate it from the bottom of my
heart means the world a big part of
what's helped make our channel so
successful is you guys going into my dms
and sending stuff like this to me andrew
garfield news we got two things to talk
about first thing on the agenda forbes
has a very interesting article and
forbes i don't know if you guys have
heard about them they are a respectable
magazine isn't that right john they are
and they know a lot about business
that's right they do especially the
movie business the second thing is i
found this one very interesting william
spencer andrew garfield stuntman may
have accidentally confirmed the amazing
spider-man 3 is happening he did comment
on what he said so we got to talk about
that but first things first forbes did
say andrew garfield likely returning as
spider-man to fight venom comma sinister
six while it's not a direct confirmation
the fact that forbes is reporting on
this and says likely makes it feel
very likely that it would occur maybe
you guys have seen us talk about this in
previous videos i think that andrew
garfield's spider-man would fit best
with what they currently have going with
the venom verse i mean we're gonna get
into spoilers here for both let there be
carnage and no way home they had the
post-credits scene where it seemed like
oh my god venom is finally about to face
off against tom holland it was like a
great one-minute tease there was a
one-minute tease and no way home where
it's like okay apparently not apparently
that's apparently that's not happening
where you belong well there's some
symbiote here so we can do black suit
spider-man and have the symbiote effect
i'm all cool maybe we don't know what
the actual plans are but i've always
thought the prospect of tom holland and
tom hardy fighting each other was a
little bit odd to me their movies it's
difficult for me to imagine a movie
where it totally fits even though i know
it's what people want it's hard for me
to really imagine what that movie would
be because even watching that post
credit scene in no way home you're like
something about this doesn't quite mesh
it does not feel like it belongs yeah in
the same universe but when we're talking
about which spider-man franchise really
would probably mesh better i've said
this several times that it would
probably be andrew garfield based off of
how much darker that one is and i feel
like cinematography wise they both have
this sort of blue tint to the way those
films are framed and i just think their
universe is ultimately would mesh best
together if we're talking about from the
three spider-man will work better with
tom hardy's it makes me think about and
warren from cosmic wonder actually
pointed this out how in spider-man no
way home one thing andrew garfield does
say when they're riffing with each other
is i'd like to fight an alien and it
just sounds like a funny line but if it
actually is a seed they plant for a
future installment for some bigger plan
that we were not made privy to i think
that'd be a really cool way to have that
actually occur so it would be an
interesting tease i ultimately think and
i do think them colliding together would
make more sense than even tom hollands
and with the way no way home ends we
assumed that it would just end with them
going back to their respective universes
but the multiverse is in chaos so we
don't really know exactly how where
they're going to be landing ultimately
tom hardy could be landing in ninja
garfield and garfield could be landing
in tamar easy you know we don't know
where they're going to be landing
ultimately and we just have to wait for
it to play out and what forbes talking
about the sinister six i have several
friends who
know
sony people and uh that's all i could
really say about that but there have
been some rumblings about sony actually
going back at it with trying to develop
a sinister six movie does put a little
bit of a wrench in it only due to the
fact that the villains were healed and
no way home so maybe it would just be
like venom morbius craving the hunter
and some other folks
i'm not sure variants of the you know
ones we saw here you never know so i
think it would be a neat way to bring
back andrew garfield if like tom holland
can still exist within the marvel
cinematic universe sony can put a
conclusion or a continuation with their
own spider-man because i think that's
something no way home sets up really
well is we can't have co-existing
spider-man without it being confusing
you would have you're into the
spider-verse franchise get your tom
holland one and then perhaps sony could
have like their andrew garfield one
which is
so tonally different than tom holland's
but it would be pretty cool i think to
ultimately see play out oh yeah
absolutely and i feel like you're
totally right in that you know andrew
garfield i think would match with tom
hardy's energy that much more especially
as compared to like a tobey maguire or
tom holland because both of them are
quirky and have these weird ticks and
mannerisms and yeah sony's universe is a
bit darker and they are clearly going
for the villain you know anti-heroes
stories and i feel like yeah that makes
the most sense to put andrew garfield's
in that world and two you know you look
at something like the morbius trailer
it's confusing as to which universe that
is because it looks like it's got
elements of all three and i wonder if
they're gonna use that to their
advantage as some kind of messy means of
going we're gonna see what people
respond to the best and then kind of run
which whichever one this is and right
now that seems to be andrew garfield i
mean if it is andrew garfield my theory
has been that that spider-man of tobey
maguire spider-man from the playstation
that was going around says murderer on
it could actually be digitally swap it
out with andrew garfield's when we
actually watched the movie which would
have make more sense still don't know
why they're calling a murderer but he
does also talk about in no way home that
he let his rage get the best of him so
maybe there is some storyline there to
unpack where he accidentally did kill
someone i'm not sure what it would be
but i think that would make it work and
also with the oscorp building this has
been pointed out several times that's
not the exact same one from the amazing
spider-man but it is the same text and
they also do mention venom in that
morbius trailer i
am
so it would work the thing that there
was a wrench in it is that maybe this
vulture is not the same vulture from the
mcu but perhaps a variant or maybe
morbius is kind of throwing everything
in it and we don't really know exactly
what the hell they're doing they're just
trying to confuse us this is where maybe
we're reaching the phase where they're
just gonna throw in a whole bunch of
things that won't actually appear just
to throw us off the center but i'll
leave the question to you beautiful sons
of [ __ ] would you want venom tom
hardy's to go up against specifically
tom hollands or would you want andrew
garfield to return and have him go up
against him leave your thoughts down
below now the thing that some people
thought might be an actual confirmation
of it all was william spencer who was
andrew garfield stunt double on
instagram someone said congratulations
on getting the call to work on tasm 3
the amazing spider-man 3 and when she
responded thank you so much so a lot of
people ran with this as this must be
confirmation right this has to be the
real confirmation however he did take it
to instagram to screenshot this moment
and say that this was just a big
misunderstanding the reason why i was
misunderstanding is because he was
getting a lot of congratulatory praise
in regards to no way home so he was
trying to just quickly reply to everyone
so when he said thank you he wasn't
really thinking about that that was
saying tasm three what he was doing was
just saying thank you i can believe that
you know if you're responding to like a
gazillion messages you're likely to say
that but the initials for tasm 3 are
very different than nwh so maybe he was
just a little confused maybe he was a
little bit tired i'm not sure what it is
another thing that there's a little bit
of a wrench in this whole thing of him
clarifying it one of the things when
stuff was getting leaked about no way
home forget exactly what the story is
you guys can put it in the comments i'd
really appreciate that he pretty much
put it out there that he was working on
no way home that led to a lot of people
solidifying the theory that he must be
there because he's andrew garfield's
stunt double and as we saw that came
true
and yes my new guy in marvel's sights
marvel's scope maybe that's what's
occurring right now is he accidentally
said a little too much and this is such
a massive plan it would really shift the
game plan for sony's spider-man universe
because this would then really make it a
full-blown spider-man universe so i
don't know i'll just take his word for
it for now that he could like that's a
very it's very believable that he would
just be replying really quick and not
really think about it but either way i
think you can count it as a safe bet
that andrew garfield will return as
spider-man in some degree pretty soon
yeah seems to be the main discussion
right now after this movie is less about
tom hall and spider-man 4 and more about
it seems that andrew garfield is indeed
returning i'm excited for it i i
absolutely love his portrayal of peter
parker spider-man i feel like it would
make sense prior to no way home it'd be
a little bit like i don't know about
this but after what we see in no way
home i think there's a good there's a
good match here anyway guys what do you
think about this piece of news do you
believe this stunt man or not thank you
guys so much for this amazing year
spider-man stuff seems to just be
ramping up even more i thought after no
way home we'd be like all right let's
cool down now it's just like blown open
a whole bunch of other doors hand off
that football to andrew
let him go let's see man there's so much
more coming subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
we got one more patron of the day shout
out
sar ben israel just when we thought we
wrapped up all of our patron of the day
shout outs he snuck in there and took
the pledge i like that about you it
takes ambition it takes knowing an
opportunity when to strike
s
stands for spider-man a stands for
amazing a e stands for awesome tacular
jeremy not renner would give you that
rating
r
stands for righteous because you are a
righteous cat b
stands for ben parker because it takes
this level
of guidance around our yep moving on to
the e john e stands for edward nigma of
a different universe entirely but we can
dream right absolutely n stands for
norman osborn because you are cunning i
stands for ivan drago
s stands for
[ __ ] spacek cause you can read minds of
when to pledge r stands for ray park who
i assume has done some stunt work in
some spider-man property somewhere a
stands for astronomical
joy e stands for elf comma flying green
no way home joke l stands for
lick me
in 2022
sure you were happy you got in here at
the last minute thanks so much for
joining us
[Music]
you